all right so Majin thanks for doing this
we've been going back and forth for four
months now I've only had the show up for
four three weeks but we've been going
back and forth for a while and you're in
New York right now you live you live in
London correct that's right yeah yeah so
you live in London so you're halfway
between Los Angeles and London so I
figured we do the Skype because I don't
know when you're gonna be out here any
any LA plans coming I don't know I mean
I'd love to come to LA and I good
friends in on the west coast but nothing
fixed yet all right it's it's good to
have this opportunity yeah all right so
we'll do the Skype thing with you in New
York me and LA so first off I saw a
picture of you that you tweeted
yesterday you were hanging out with
Morgan Freeman in a mosque so what was
that about yes this is what's brought me
here to to New York I can't explain too
much of it at the moment all I can say
is that I had a great conversation with
him in the in the Islamic Center of New
York we spent a good hour or so having a
chat about the distinctions between
Islam and Islamism and about my story
and the work I do but beyond that we're
just gonna have to wait and see what I
was up to all right well now he's played
God so I guess he's the right guy to
talk to on that in in the house of God I
was speaking to a man that played God
about God all right there you go okay so
I want to talk to you about some of the
things that you probably did speak with
him bad so first let's just start with
your story because you're your biography
what you've lived through to get to here
is really really incredible so can you
just sort of sum that up in a couple
minutes
you know those who want the as you know
the full story it's in my memoir called
radical but but in a in a summarized
form basically I joined a revolutionary
Islamist group at the age of 16 years
old I ended up on the leadership of this
organization and spent 13 years with
them and I played my role in exporting
this organization from Britain to
Pakistan and then to Denmark and
eventually to to Egypt the group's name
was his battalion it was the first among
these Lewis groups to popular reaction
of resurrecting a caliphate that would
seek to conquer other countries and
enforce their version of Islam as law
and their method by which they aimed to
come to power was via military cooze so
we were very much focused in recruiting
army officers to join our organization
and then inciting them towards military
coups and that's what took me to
Pakistan is what eventually took me to
Egypt I arrived one day before the 9/11
attacks and then ten months later I
found myself arrested and detained and
taken to the torture dungeons of Egypt's
state security headquarters in Cairo and
then sentenced after four months in
solitary confinement sentenced to five
years in prison as a political prisoner
that's at that point is when Amnesty
International adopted me as a prisoner
of conscience began campaigning for my
release because of course so we had
views that I now find repugnant and what
describe is extreme we were and we and a
group still is non non terrorist which
is why it's still legal in America and
animus across Europe so it's it's the
distinction I draw between an Islamist
group and a jihadist group is that if
Islamism is the desire to impose any
interpretation of Islam over Society
jihadism is the use of force to spread
Islamism and and jihadist terrorism is
the use of force to spread Islamism by
targeting civilians the group that I
joined was an Islamist group it wasn't a
jihadist group right so I'm glad you
made that distinction because I do find
that when we're having this conversation
and it's being had by so many different
people in so many different forms that
just the definitions alone are lost and
I know you've done a lot of work trying
to just explain that kind of stuff to
people so they're able to understand
what we're talking about here yeah
positive the problem is because this is
a phenomenon that we've never really
dealt with before in terms of human
beings have never really dealt with this
phenomenon off of ideological Islam
seeking a very Bolshevik form of control
totalitarian control over Society we
simply as people didn't have the lexicon
to have these conversations so though I
use these definitions you won't find
these definitions taught in universities
or in academic terms because people will
dealt with a problem before so part of
the challenge that we faced was in
coming up with very crystal
clear logical definitions and then
popularizing them and so you often
you'll find that I repeat myself a lot
and it doesn't I repeat myself is
because you know we have to to
popularize these terms and to popularize
these concepts can only come through
repetition until everyone finally begins
to understand and it got to a point
where the Prime Minister of the UK
understood yeah okay so you spent about
five years in an Egyptian prison now
that was under Mubarak at the time who
technically I supposed he was known as
the president but he basically was a
dictator that was backed by the US for
about thirty years what was that like
being in an Egyptian prison I can't
imagine well it wasn't a pleasant
experience at all you know we had the
torture first of all for the first four
days and then we were put into solitary
confinement for four months and I was
held in a Cell as were all of us in that
period of solitary confinement in cells
where in which we had no sanitation no
lights no no beds we had nothing but the
bare concrete cell in which to in which
to try and get through without without
going insane and so I have with me
actually I want to show you this because
I had a when I was arrested I had a
pocket-sized version of the Quran which
is this in my hand here this this
particular Quran has been with me from
the day of my rest all the way through
the torture dungeons through the
solitary confinement and then through
through the four years in prison and and
one of the things I did is in the
solitary confinement we didn't have any
any light to read so and obviously the
mind can wonder in that sort of
situation and and you fear for your own
sanity so one of the things I would do
is stand by the by the door of the of
the jail cell look for the wait for the
light to seep in through the bars and
then I would stand there and read if you
can see it's a very small the text is
actually tiny yeah well you know I would
read that I ended up memorizing half of
it I'm just living in my jail cell but
it was you know it was these sorts of
things and it's why I've kept this hills
these sorts of things that kept me from
going mad during the solitary
confinement period and another thing I
want to show you is this this is um this
is a radio which I had with me
it's a sort of it was given to me by the
British Embassy and it was actually on
this thing that I heard first time that
we'd be charged we we hadn't been for
informed well officially but the BBC
World Service had reported it and so I
was listening to it on this and we found
out there with that we've been charged
and we was go to trial and and finally I
think this picture is up on the internet
but I have the original with me and this
is something I stole from prison and
I've kept it with me ever since because
it means a lot to me this is the mug
shot that was taken of me so that that's
the day and that's the very day we were
dragged from the torture dungeons to be
thrown into solitary so that's before I
was actually before I was actually put
into solitary confinement that's me at
24 years old and there you see what you
see is my my name in Arabic graduate old
man no one's and there is a prison
number and what I've done of course
since then is I've taken that number
which is in Arabic two four five three
and I have tattooed it on my back as a
reminder for me actually of those days
and where I've come from which was your
original question and the journey made
to get to where I am now
yeah it's such an incredible journey one
other thing on the jail thing I find
that fascinating that they let you keep
a copy of the Quran with you because
wasn't Mubarak basically not that he was
secular per se but they were you know
the Muslim Brotherhood was illegal under
him you would think that he would want
no sign of religion to get the prisoners
to uprise or something like that yet he
let you have it or they want the country
on the country now I'm not gonna I'm not
about to defend Mubarak I cheered when
he was he was held in the same cell that
he held me and afterwards soon I'm not
I'm not here in any way to defend Hosny
Mubarak what I would say is that the
Egyptian dictator as his regime
already understood the distinction that
I now made between Islam and Islamism
their problem wasn't us holding copies
of the Quran their problem was the
interpretation that we spun and they
would encourage us to study traditional
medieval Islam because they knew that
medieval Islam wasn't Islamism and they
would encourage us to be exposed to
theologians from Azhar University which
we were in prison and their books so
that we could read about this um from
its medieval era and understand it
wasn't this modern archaeological forum
that we've come to a dot now I say this
and I say it with a caveat that of
course traditional ultra-conservative
medieval Islam also needs to be reformed
you know it's it's not the pinnacle it's
not that kind of you know the the
epitome of of civil liberties however
what we what we have to accept anyone
who knows the basic the basic thing the
most basic thing about Islamic history
and the development of Islamic theology
well know for all of its faults and
there are plenty of faults by the way
and you know fundamentalism largely owes
a debt to sort of the fact that they see
Muslims generally still Revere that
medieval period of our theology and
haven't developed it since but it's
still very different to what the
Islamist project is and and the Egyptian
authorities knew that so they would
encourage us you know they would rather
we were conservative religious or
fundamentalist Muslims than members of
the Muslim Brotherhood yeah that's so
fascinating and even if you think about
what's going on with Egypt now where we
sort of have another version of Mubarak
and Sisi and sort of controlling things
and yet you know the Muslim Brotherhood
was in charge for a year and we backed
them too but that's a whole other topic
so before we move on to some of the
other stuff I saw a clip where you were
on Real Time with Bill Maher from about
a year ago and on the overtime segment
you recounted a story about a bomb maker
that you met in jail and I was hoping
you could you could just sum that up
real quick because I thought I thought
it was fascinating and it goes yeah very
much what you're talking about right now
yeah sure um so in prison there was a we
were imprisoned with the who's who of
the Giada's scene at the time we had the
assassins of learned of almost of Egypt
I was about who was killed in 1981 the
group was known as Tom Rieman jihad
those who weren't executed in that case
well with us in prison we have a leader
of the Muslim Brotherhood dr. Muhammad
and Padilla's since been reincarnated as
you mentioned he wasn't the leader of
the Brotherhood
he since became the leader of the
Brotherhood but he and his entire
leadership were with me in prison we
have the leadership of his material and
we also had people that came from abroad
and the the bomb-maker that you referred
to
he particular was from Dagestan next
door to Chechnya and they he came via
Afghanistan to Egypt in an attempt to
cross that are crossing into Gaza to
teach how much how to make bombs but he
was caught by the Egyptian authorities
and they imprisoned him they sentenced
him to 17 years and I became friendly
with this man and had a long
conversation with him due to the the
London bombings because you know the
invasion of Iraq happened when I was
imprisoned and the London the 7/7
attacks in London the bombings and sort
of the buses in the tubes in London also
happened when I was in prison so I liked
it I could have got locked into a long
conversation with this with this man
about the in his view the legitimacy of
attacking London and I was attempting to
convince him that it wasn't legitimate
now again because I used to belong to a
non terrorist yet revolution extreme
Islamist group we didn't believe in
Jihad
there's Impa to come to power so we were
arguing with the jihadists that actually
what they should be focusing on is in
military coups and that's why I was
opposing him not because I hadn't yet
left I hadn't yet left Islamism it's
because my form of Islamism in its
method had you know was very different
to his in its sort of how it seeks to
come to power sure but one thing I you
know I'm really proud of is that here's
a man who was trained was fully capable
of of making bombs and then causing
mayhem and mayhem and havoc so yeah when
I put it to him that the justification
he uses to to say that it's legitimate
to target British citizens in that they
voted for their government would be the
same justification one could use for
Turk's
voted for their government in Turkey as
a member of NATO and NATO as an alliance
was involved in Afghanistan and so and
so why wouldn't he be bombing Turkey and
his answer that he the answer he gave me
was a pragmatic one not a religious one
at which point I caught him out and I
said you see so you know what you're
doing is you're playing politics you're
giving me a pragmatic answer which is a
very thing when Bush does it you
criticize Bush for
the upshot of that conversation was by
the end of it you know it took him a
couple of days or whatever he not to my
my jail cell and he came back looking
really sheepish and he said you know
I've been thinking about what you said
and I think you're right and I just
don't agree with you it's it's not
justified to attack British civilians
and one of the things that really swung
him was the the fact that so many in the
UK protested against the Iraq war so my
argument to him was how can you be
attacking these people but I'm happy you
know he changed his mind I don't know
where he is or what he's doing now but
that's you know that's it's a small
incremental step towards peace and
reconciliation and it was one of the
first examples that I felt sent me on
the path that I'm now on